If we could
go back to the
picture that we just showed a second ago,
he was looking off to the distance.
He looked really irritated and annoyed.
It was a profile photo
that we just showed. There it is.
I mean, Jamie Gangel,
you've been covering Donald Trump
for a long time.
That is a pissed off Donald Trump.
Right.
You know, this is not defiant.
We've seen pictures
that sort of were sobering.
No question.
That is an angry
Donald Trump is Two things to point out
in addition
to the fact
that no one held the door open for him.
We had been told that he was likely going
to stop in the hallway
and speak on his way,
insisting or texting.
It did not happen.
And I have to wonder
if one of the reasons it didn't happen
is because he's in custody
and they would not allow it
to happen on the way in.
The other thing
I just wanted to
mention is
I spoke
to people who
have been in civil cases with him before.
We see the public, Donald Trump.
We see what he posts.
We see all this fighting and bravado.
And
I am told that when he's in a courtroom
and I would think even more
so in a criminal case,
that he's going to be respectful
of this judge
who not too long ago he posted
and he said, the judge
assigned to my witch hunt case,
a case that's never been charged
before, capital letters hates me.
I'm guessing
we will hear a very different report.
And I'm being told by a source
in New York government
that the indictment has been unsealed,
although it's not live yet
on the website.
As John Miller reported
several days ago,
it is 34 charges against Donald Trump.
And I'm told that he pleaded
not guilty to all 34 of those charges.
And now, of course,
we wait to see what those charges are.
Carrie Cordero.
Yeah, well,
I mean,
so so
we'll see what the actual substance
of these charges are
and whether they pertain to more crimes
or whether they just
are that many charges,
because that's each count
of a particular financial transaction,
like a check.
But as we're waiting to see what
the text of that charging document
actually is,
as we're watching these visuals,
one of the things that stands out to me
is just this dichotomy
between, on one hand, the justice system
trying to treat the former president
like any other defendant.
So going through the normal process,
saying
having taken that time
where he had to be behind the scenes
and fingerprinted
and processed through
whatever paperwork
needed to be done in New York.
But the other side of the screen
showing the extensive security procedures
and all of the police presence
that's there
and the fact that there is not the public
in the seats behind the defendant
and this room is not open to the public,
just shows how not normal
this situation is,
despite the justice system.
Maybe trying to make this sort
of the way
other defendants would be treated.
It's just not that way.
This is a completely unique yeah.
No, I mean,
it is an interesting balance
of trying to act as though
we are all equal under the law.
And Donald Trump will be treated
no differently than anybody else.
While also obviously
he is a former president
and this has never happened before.
Andy McCabe.
And also,
you know, to be fair,
I don't know
that a case like this
would be brought against Donald
Trump real estate developer
for the same alleged.
I mean, who knows?
Maybe it would be.
But on the other hand, who knows?
It's really hard to say at this point,
having not seen the indictment yet.
Right.
But that's that's a decision
that I think
each one of us has to come to
after reading the document.
The the DA's office
certainly maintains
that they bring this charge
of falsification of business records
and sometimes with the felony enhancement
on a fairly regular basis
against white collar defendants.
But again, we
don't know
what's going to be in this
in this document.
I will say, though, Jake,
that these photographs
of the former president are so striking.
But to me, they are very familiar
in a way over a course of over 20 years.
And the FBI, having been
with numerous people
on arrest and arraignment day.
There is an undeniable
humility and humanity
that comes out against
whoever has been called
before the court and accused
publicly of a crime in this process.
Whether you're
you know,
I've seen it from street level criminals
all the way up to CEOs and white collar
people accused of white collar offenses.
This moment
you may be sitting next to your lawyers,
but you are alone before a judge
and before the law
and facing some very serious allegations.
And it is a moment
that that he will never forget,
his family will never forget.
And it's a it's a somber thing about
and he is an individual,
of course, very wealthy
to the manor born
who has
in many ways escaped
consequences for actions
for decades and decades.
So I could see why
sitting at that table
would be particularly humbling.
He probably never thought he would ever
have to.
Well, of course,
we are still waiting to find out
what exactly the charges are.
But just a report.
Repeat my reporting from before
the indictment has been unsealed.
A source in New York government tells me.
It is not live yet on the website,
but there are 34 charges.
And I am told from this source
in New York government
that Donald Trump
pleaded not guilty to all 34 counts.